hello everyone and welcome to the
semi-finals of the 2022 fide grand prix
it's lavon arenan versus linear
dominguez perez and levon pretty much uh
i just placed through the the
quarterfinals he was unstoppable whereas
uh the linear the uh fight a bit more he
went into the tie breaks the win with
wesley so we've seen a game from
yesterday uh he had a brilliant
brilliant win against wesley in that
game two of the tie breaks so now uh
we'll see what happens in this one this
is game one of their classical match
levon has the white pieces and we will
have a very exciting queens gambit
accepted so i hope you are ready for
that so levon with the white pieces
opens with d4 uh we have d5 while near
c4 and not d captures on c4 so you know
there's going to be a good fight already
uh we have e4 grabbing the center very
principled uh by levon and now b5
defending the c4 pawn
we have a4 undermining the uh the pawn
chain and now c6 we are adding a
defender to the b5 pawn it captures on
b5c captures and now just knife to c3
going after that b5 phone and this is
already incredibly tricky just to give
you an example if you try and defend it
with a6 we can pick it up with knight
captures and b5 but blank will capture
this and then we were we will give up
the rook and a8 bishop the b7 uh give
sacrifice the exchange rook to a1 and
bishop captures an e4 with extremely
complicated play if white isn't um
uh well sure of what he's doing uh
things could go very very wrong for
white uh but in most of these lines you
will you will be giving up the rook here
that's how now the queen's gambit
accepted is played nowadays so here
queen to b6 by linear and knight to d5
going after the queen on b6 we have
queen to b7 now if the knight moves we
will have pressure on that e4 pawn and
bishop to f4 now threatening knight to
c7 check the window rook here
and you can't really play knight to the
a6 to guard the c7 square this will be
because we just pick it up a rook
captures queen captures and now we have
this monster royal fork uh black is just
destroyed here so instead we have e5
here this is the only move for black so
now there's a unique set of moves that
you really have to know if you want to
play this bishop capture 75 and only now
knight to d7 now black is even inviting
whites to play knight to c7 check
because here after king to d8 what do
you what do you play
it's not a great position for white your
bishop is hanging and also if the bishop
moves somewhere weird the knight is
hanging as well and if you capture the
rook which is pretty much what you came
here to do there's bishop to be for
check and the white can resign you
either give up the queen or you play
king to e2 and then queen capture sun e4
is checkmate so that's how that's how
complicated the queen's gambit accepted
is so after knight to d7 levon just
brings the bishop back bishop to f4 and
now it's not only moving the bishop back
one square you're also uh defending it
against this bishop to be for check
after knights to c7 check so now the
bishop will be able to block as well so
here we have knight g to f6 uh linear
continuous development and the knight
the c7 with checks so now levon will
grab the exchange king to d8 knight
captures on e8 and now like we said
bishop to b for check isn't all that
impressive now because we can play
bishop to d2 our bishop is not an e5 so
queen captures an e4 check first bishop
blocks uh sorry knight blocks check
uh so we also defend our bishop on f4
and now queen captures an a8
we have f3 now uh grabbing more uh
control over the central squares also
keeping an eye on this knight on f6 so
it can't really jump around uh but of
course it can go to d5 which is exactly
what linear does he attacks the bishop
now and uh there is a game where king
the f2 was played it's kind of a move
you you want to play because you are not
castling normally here you have to cast
artificially so king on f2 will be very
very good but first we have bishop to g5
check and it is only now as of move 15
that we have a completely new game uh so
dominguez stops this with f6 we have
bishop back to d2 and now bishop to d6
continuing development
we ignite the g3 now with ideas of king
to f2 bishop to e2 and finally bringing
the rook into the game but uh eleanor
has something to say about this he plays
queen to b8 and puts pressure on white's
knight here so now if you just play
bishop to e2 we're gonna very happily
capture here win upon and bring our
queen all the way to g3 so king f2 we
add another defender to the knight first
rook to e8 now the rook gets into the
game and the bishop to e2 so now white
is ready to finally bring that rook to
e1
so bishop to c7
here maybe uh just a6 and continue
continue to play this okay you are down
the exchange but you have very very nice
pressure you have you still have the
bishop pair if those pawns start
marching down the board it's going to be
very difficult for white to stop them
but here uh linear has a very different
idea he plays bishop to c7 we have rook
to e1 levon uh got his work into the
game and now you again have to play this
a6 move and just uh keep it keep it a
solid structure but here bishop the b6
was played and now this is a problem you
no longer have this uh incredible
pressure on the on the g3 square and now
levon just hides the king on g1 so now
now there is no bishop captures on g3
and levon is very happy with his
position so here at knight to e5 uh you
could also capture the pawn on d4 with
check but just king h1 levon would very
happily give up this pawn to play king
h1 because look at the position now
the white king
very nicely artificially castled on h1
and the black king stuck in the center
of the board this is not a position you
want to play against lebon so instead
knight to e5 as the d-pawn is pinned
so king to h1 again welcoming this
opportunity we have knight back to c6
now putting even more pressure on this
spawn and it seems like black is doing
fine but remember the black king is
still in the center of the board and
also uh black is just lost here so how
are we going to approach this position
feel free to pause the video here and
win the game for white while i give you
a couple of seconds
so for those of you who are able to do
it congratulations on once again
realizing that the king is in the center
of the board and we have to open up
lines towards the black king and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it is of course pawn to b3
that's how we are going to open lines uh
and now of course if captures we're just
going to capture on b5 so black will not
capture but also you can't just do
nothing because just the b cap presents
c4 and not only is your kink still in
the center of the board you're losing
material so c3 was played but this isn't
much better yes you are attacking the
bishop on d2 but still the one just
captures on b5 and now the problem is uh
if you capture on d2 we're just gonna
capture on e8 with check after king
capture spawn captures here with check
and we're gonna pick up the knight as
well king to the eight or somewhere
bishop captures here and now we are up a
full rook because we were already up the
exchange so uh we are now up a full rook
so instead after bishop captures on b5
we have bishop to d7 by dominguez and
now rook captures on e8 bishop captures
on e8 and now uh bishop
back to e1 as your bishop is still
hanging here a bit of a cleaner
execution would be just captures
captures and bishop to e1 because you uh
pretty much eliminate uh black's counter
play but that's of course easier said
than done and i think levon was also
playing on uh linear's time because
levon has over an hour and the clock
linear is already below 10 minutes so
here just bishop to e1 and now okay now
you give up the d4 pawn we have bishop
capture 78 but now you allow the black
to throw in this very very unpleasant
pawn to c to move and
well okay it's uh it's an ugly position
for black but also there's a past pawn
on c2 which is never never very
comfortable so queen to d3 white is
still okay here we have king capture 78
and now comes bishop d2 by lavon and
like i said levon still has over an hour
on the clock and he is winning here but
he has to play it very very precisely
however he plays bishop to d2 and he
allows uh uh linear to get back into the
game uh the thing is you really uh
i don't want to give black um
you know a moment's breath you have to
play knight to e2 put pressure on the
knight now you're threatening to win
material and once black defends this
let's say queen e5 now we just trade
knight captures and if bishop captures
rook to c1 we really want to get rid of
this pawn here so knight the e3 black
will defend it and now bishop g3 we
attack the queen after queen to c5 we
play bishop to f2 again our plan is to
capture the knight and then pick up the
pawn so black will again try and trick
us now he says all right you can capture
the knight now but then after i capture
uh you you will not be able to capture
because of queen to a1 and you will be
in a lot of trouble so we're just gonna
have to play f4 here for example and
after queen captures now we play this
captures captures and queen rook
captures on c2 of course and we are up
the exchange and winning this game uh
however levon again i think he was
playing in linear time played bishop to
d2 and now it's a little bit different
queen to e5 and what can you play now uh
well rook to c1
uh you're still hoping to somehow win
the c2 pawn but now uh we have f5 here
and it's uh
it's very very hard to play this for
both black and white we have queen to c4
uh and now the thing is uh the reason
that i said that um lemon messed up and
he uh lost his advantage is that if
black finds uh the correct continuation
here then it's fine for black but if not
he is completely lost and here you have
to find f4 i'm just going to show it to
you because it's impossible to find
but f4
saves black
the point is you you have to prevent
white from playing f4 that's that's the
problem and now after the knight moves
now you play knight to e3 you defend
your pawn once again and your position
is uh well very enjoyable and you don't
care about queen c8 check you don't care
about queen to g8 check we can quickly
show for example queen g8 check king
here and if queen f7 check we can block
queen e7 uh there's no continuation here
with white and even if you try uh queen
to c8 with check it's pretty much the
same thing king f7 queen d7 check now
you can play king to g6 and this is very
similar to what actually happened in the
game with one uh huge difference and
that is uh
linear did not play f4 he started with
knight to e3 right away and now you will
see the difference this uh f4 move makes
so here we have queen to c8 with check
interestingly now both queen c8 and
queen g8 are winning uh without the
inclusion of the f4 move so queen to c8
check king to f7 and now queen to d7
check and now you finally see why df4 is
so important because now if queen e7 we
just pick up the queen and after king
captures the knight is hanging the f4
was not played
so after queen d7 check king the g6 was
played and now of course there is uh
only one winning move for white but i
don't even have to ask you guys to pause
the video because we've already said it
many times uh write the play and win
white of course plays pawn to f4 and
this is the only winning move uh because
we have to get to the queen away from
there and we have to prevent black from
playing f4 so here elevon played this uh
beautiful f4 move and now what do you
play uh the the thing is if you capture
on f4 then you'll no longer control the
e file queen e8 check and now you're
getting destroyed if king to g5 we can
just play uh bishop captures an e3 and
the queen is lost the queen on e8
controls the bishop here and also if you
play something like king here knights to
h5 a nice royal fork you will lose the
queen this way so after f4 dominguez has
to go back we have queen to e6 offering
a queen trade but now olive one can just
trade down into a winning endgame
because we have to remember he is still
up the exchange black only had a very
very active play uh but uh you know once
everything gets traded off that no
longer holds any importance so here are
queen captures on e6 knight captures and
knight to e to now you could play this
many ways uh levon finds the the
simplest and the strongest continuation
that is just 92 we control the f4 square
so we're not going to give up our pawn
and now we are ready to pick up the
knight of course even g3 defend the pawn
pick up the knight remove the defender
of the c2 pawn and then rook captures on
c2 so that's pretty much all there is
and uh it's still moved 36 so four more
moves to reach time control levon some
55 minutes on the clock and uh dominguez
some
five minutes on the clock so knight the
g4 was played he wants to try some
knight to f2 ideas but uh still will not
um do all that much the idea is if rook
captures we're gonna deliver this check
and now go knight g for check where we
are hoping for a repetition or if king
f1 knight captures an h2 we pick up a
pawn with check and so on but still uh
should be very good for white however
leveling just plays g3 this is the
absolute best we have knight to c5 uh
this move was made with three seconds on
the clock for for the linear uh we have
b4 challenging the knight knight to d3
attacking the rook and finally the pass
pawn is eliminated rook captures on c2
we have knight g to f2 with checking to
g2 knight to e4
and now as this move was played this is
now move 40 so time control has been
reached uh but uh there is no more point
in continuing here levon played knight
to c1 and he was in this position on
move 41 that linear dominguez perez uh
resigned the game as there is nothing
more to be done here so you're down the
exchange and that's pretty much it you
you have nothing to show for it um there
are no tricks you can try there are no
you know you could play some night here
and i'd hear ideas but still for example
night here it looks very scary you have
two knights in front of the white king
uh but the white king just laughs in
your face and says i'm on a light square
your knights can't touch me the bishop
is a dark square bishop so i'm perfectly
perfectly safe here so of course uh
a linear doesn't want to try and do do
something here because now we've reached
move 40 and additional time has been
acquired by both players so really an
exciting game queen's gambit accepted
always a fireworks on the board and you
can see how uh it all came down to here
uh where uh linear uh
uh found this weird plan of bishop c7 to
b6 whereas the bishop is really nicely
placed here really prevents white from
just normally playing rookie one and
king back to g2 g1 because the knight
will get to destroy the knight cannot
move otherwise you pick up the h2 pawn
so
it's
you know everything is a great as it is
and i say six here and the game goes on
but
i guess this is where where the
preparation uh uh ended and uh well it
seems that uh he didn't think the bishop
was as important here and also the d4
pawn is undefended so it seems like you
should be okay here that maybe white
should waste the move defending it but
as lavon showed no not really so yeah
that's the game hope you guys enjoyed it
i would like to thank uh sorry about
that in this position feel free to pause
the video uh jonathan camp uh fork and
tributions to my channel uh kanji and
david bryan for a contribution to my
channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check two
of my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the feeder
grand prix semifinals until the end so
thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your weekend